الاحتياطي الفيدرالي رفع اسعار الفائده
بنسبه 25 نقطه اساس المزيد طبعا من
التحليل حول مبيعات قرار الفيدرالي على
الاسواق تنضم الينا الزميله نادين هاني من
قسم الاقتصاد نادين يعني هذا الرفع كان
متوقع كيف
سيتلقفه او ستتلقفه الاسواق بعد ازمه
البنوك الاخيره وهل هناك رفع اخر متوقع
ليان لا شك بانه من بعد الاحداث الاخيره
اصلا كان تغيرت التوقعات يعني بالاجتماع
السابق كنا نتوقع ان يرفع الفيدرالي
بخمسين نقطه اساس من بعد ازمه البنوك
تراجعت توقعات الى ربع نقطه مئويه
الفيدرالي لا يفاجئ الاسواق عاده اذا كان
احتماليه بالسوق توقعات 85% كانت انه يرفع
ربع نقطه مئويه بالفعل هو بيرفع مثل
توقعات السوق لا يحب مفاجاه الاسواق
بالنسبه لهم مهم جدا مع الاسواق رساله
خاطئه للاسواق هو اللي تغير هو توقعات
المستقبليه اها رح فسر الان اكزاكلي شو
اللي تغير بالكلام بالنسبه للرفعه
المستقبلي خفت التوقعات الان بالنسبه لحجم
الرفع بالاجتماعات القادمه فلنستمع لك
نادين تفاصيل معك تفضلي شكرا اذا مشاهدينا
رفع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي قبل قليل
اسعار الفائده بربع نقطه مئويه لتصل الى
5% هي الاعلى منذ العام 2007 جاء قرار
الفيدرالي متماشيا كما ذكرنا مع اغلب
توقعات المحللين على الرغم من مطالبات عده
بوقف رفع اسعار الفائده خاصه بعد ازمه
تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه الاسبوع الماضي
واستبدل بيان الفيدرالي عباره رفع مستمر
للفائده بالنسبه لتوقعات المستقبليه
استبدلها بتوقعات الاعضاء بان المزيد من
التشديد في السياسه النقديه قد يكون
مناسبا للوصول بتضخم الى مستوى اثنين
بالمئه وتعليقا على الازمه الحاليه للبنوك
اشار البيان الى ان القطاع المصرفي متين
لكن الاحداث الاخيره ممكن ان تؤدي الى
تشديد في شروط الائتمان وتاثير سلبيا على
النمو الا ان حجم تاثير لا يزال غير واضح